- [whispers indistinctly]
- WHAT? MY YOGURT?
IN THE BREAK ROOM?
OH, MY GO--
I GOTTA CALL YOU BACK.
ABOUT TO CATCH ME A CASE.
YO, LET'S GO!
YOU DON'T EAT A MAN'S YOGURT.
THAT'S ALL I CAN EAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
I'M ON A DIET.
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
SOMEONE EATIN' MY YOGURT.
- FIGHT?
- I WILL KILL A MAN
RIGHT NOW.
- WHO'S FIGHTING?
IS SOMEONE FIGHTING?
FIGHT! FIGHT!
- YOU CAN'T BE SNACKIN'
ON MY SNACKS LIKE THAT!
- GIMME THE NEWS, NOT
THE DICK BREATH, YA BUTT SLUG!
I'LL EAT WHAT I WANT!
- YOU GOT NO RESPECT
FOR ANOTHER MAN'S LIVE CULTURES.
WE ABOUT TO GET IT ON!
- OKAY, LET'S GO!
[all shouting at once]
- GET OFF MY COUSIN!
- GET OFF ME! GET OFF ME!
- WATCH IT, DUDE.
- OKAY, WHAT THE HELL
IS GOING ON IN HERE?
- LISTEN, LADY,
WHY DON'T YOU JUST--
[charming Muzak plays]
WHY DON'T I APOLOGIZE
TO EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
FOR WHAT I JUST DID--
TOTALLY UNCALLED FOR.
I'M SORRY, EVERYONE.
- SURE. GREAT.
WHAT ARE YOU?
- HE'S MY COUSIN!
[laughter]
- OF COURSE HE IS.
- AND SINCE WE'RE HIRING,
I FIGURED HE'D BE
A GREAT MEMBER
OF THE SALES TEAM, RIGHT?
PLUS, HE'S A LOCAL HERO.
- YEAH. HE SURE IS.
JUMPED IN FRONT OF A FIRE TRUCK,
SAVED A LITTLE GIRL'S LIFE.
- MISS, I PROMISE YOU
I WILL GIVE YOU MY BEST,
AND I WILL DELIVER.
- ALL RIGHT, WHATEVER,
BUT YOU THREE
ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR TRAINING HIM.
AND IF HE DOESN'T DELIVER,
IT'S ON YOU.
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING AT?
COME ON, LET'S GO!
- HE ATE MY YOGURT.
- TEAM DEMAMP!
YES. AW, DUDE, WE JUST
GOT YOU A JOB. TEAM DEMAMP.